hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar automated surveillance for deep
characterization of the tumor micro
environment using ultra high content
imaging i am jennifer woods of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotech to learn more
visit miltonibbiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
telma santos
global product manager for ultra high
content imaging at miltoni biotech and
dr nizar youssef global product manager
immunology immuno oncology at miltoni
biotech
telma and nizar you may now begin your
presentations
thank you very much and thank you
everyone for joining today's webinar
i am dr thomas santos and together with
my colleague dr nizar youssef we will be
presenting
our
webinar named automated surveillance for
a deep characterization of the tumor
micro environment using ultra high
content imaging
and i hope you can appreciate this very
nice uh
um image that we made it's actually made
with uh a composite of a real sample
that you actually will see later and the
background has just been changed it is
very nice still color but all over it's
still a real microscopy image and
we will be diving of course in a more
scientific talk but it's also very nice
and you can with your science produce
quite the piece of art
so i will briefly introduce the agenda
for today
um i will start with a short
introduction i will talk a little bit
about our technology and
our imaging platform components
then my colleague will deep dive into
the scientific aspect of it and we'll
talk more about the importance of ultra
high content imaging in the tme research
and we'll show you a couple of data from
different types of cancer and we will
end up with a very nice summary before
we can take some questions
i will not go too deep into this part
but i couldn't start without just
referring to the tumor micro environment
which is at the center of our talk as we
all know
the environment around the tumor is
quite heterogeneous we all know that but
we still cannot fathom exactly
how heterogeneous it is
we have a guess
but it is clear that we need a vast
range set of tools that can allow us to
study this complexity at this level of
complexity
here i'm showing you what is the gold
standard methods in uh in atlas
pathology
we have the uh hematoxylin using
staining which is used quite often to
determine what the sample looks like we
have chromogenic immunoisochemistry that
helps you select a specific marker and
see it
and we use also now more and more
immunofluorescence
as you can see here in this nice uh
image of a tonsil
the human tongue cell
but as you can see
because you would recognize that a
composite has normally this kind of
colors we often do
three plaques four plex sometimes
pushing it
to show
different markers
but this is quite limited
we always need some markers that are the
standard ones and if we want to go
deeper into describing new ones or new
combinations this can get very
complicated very fast
but why is it that we are limited
when it comes to immunofluorescence we
are limited actually
by the light spectrum
and the properties of our fluorophores
they overlap often although we have a
lot of a lot of available fluorophores
they often overlap and makes it very
difficult almost impossible to
distinguish them um therefore just using
them at the same time is not really an
option
but what if we were not limited by the
spectrum because we would just simply
use the same plural chromes or sets of
fluorochromes in each cycle
again and again
in this way we could have so many
markers right and that is exactly what
the mix technology is about
it stands for maxima imaging cyclic
staining
[Music]
and does exactly that and it is as a
classic elegant as you imagine is that
simple
the mixed technology happens in the
maxima imaging platform
this is an instrument we developed at
miltoni
and basically what he does is that it
iteratively
does cyclic staining it stains the
sample image the sample and erase it
but let me show you a bit more how it
works in an easy way
basically take your sample your fixed
sample and this is important you fix
your sample you prepare your sample
and you put it in the maxima you take
your reagents and you put them in a
plate prepared so the maxima can pipet
it
and then you'll have a sample that is
unstained
and then the maxima will pipette to your
antibody or antibody
cocktail take a picture
and then erase the signal
and therefore after erasure we can start
all over again just like at the first
cycle
you stay in it with another set of
antibodies
you image it you will raise it
etc and so on and so forth and just that
way you can do it
and
very high amount of times actually we
don't even know what is the limit
um you can continue as long as you have
antibodies actually to stain with our
current record was 400 because we had
400 in our hands
and it's quite impressive i must say
so let me show it just
what one way of how it looks like
so here you have a sample of breast
cancer that you will that my colleague
will talk about a bit more in detail
later and he can pre i hope you can
appreciate how amazing it is to have
just this amount of different markers in
a single sample
and how um
yeah how such of a breakthrough this is
to be able to have so many markers now
um and of course my colleague will be a
bit more deep into what it means
scientifically speaking
and now just the end i would like to
just uh finish by explaining a bit more
what we mean when we say an imaging
platform
the maximum imaging platform does not
refer only to this quite pretty i must
say instruments
it is a full solution this is what we
want to do is to provide a full solution
here
and when you
have a maxima instrument
you we also have available at miltoni
sample carriers that can accommodate a
vast range of different samples so we
have here our maxwell imaging frames
these frames have different sizes for
the cavity reaction and here you can
mount any kind of
a very basic or a standard microscope
slide with your fixed sample
on it
and then you'll be able to uh insert it
in the machine and then do the cyclic
styling staining but of course if you
also do not work with tissue but cells
we have the option of
the maxwell 24 here where you can
cultivate your cells fix them regularly
and then
have them in the machine also to perform
cyclic staining
very soon we will also get a range of
what we call our micro cavities families
micro micro cavities we will have them
in different formats one that is a slide
format that can be used in the maxwell
and also a plate format and these
disposables basically have
millions of micro cavities that can
accommodate the cell and this is perfect
for
cell suspension studies
besides having the
what you need from your sample at
miltoni we also thrive to have for you
the best
antibodies
the best reagents
and we have actually a very big range of
mixed validated antibodies and one we
mean by that is that these antibodies
have been tested
in this technology
already so they are already validated
we also offer a couple of different
technologies we have different erasures
mechanisms
and one part is the realising here daily
technology which is our
gentle
signal erasure
mechanism and we also have
these pre
made
plates antibody plates dried reagent
plates that you
don't even need to pipe at your
antibodies you basically put it in the
machine and the machine will
reconstitute the dried antibodies and
will pipet them into your sample
reducing even more how much you have to
pipette before starting your experiment
it is also important to just mention
that although we have a vast range of
mixed validated antibody
this is not a completely closed platform
uh because of the classical
nature of our technology being that our
antibodies are linked to fluorophores
are primarily
conjugated with fluorophores it is quite
easy
for someone to
just use external antibodies
given if they meet our
certain dependencies for it which are
not very difficult
but the important part is that we have
antibodies but you can also use
different ones this is not a closed
system
and uh last but not least i just wanted
to mention that with the maxima imaging
platform also comes a very good image
analysis software this is not just
something that was added with a couple
of add-ons but this can really really
make your research complete it's from a
to z you have your sample you start with
a sample and a set of antibodies and you
can end up with real results this is a
software that was specifically made for
the maxima
data that can handle so many markers
that can do a very big set of um
of analysis analysis uh we have analysis
tools that are state of the art um and
of course it is highly intuitive
interactive and i would really really um
advise to contact us if you have if you
want to have a look because this is
something from another world
um
but i might sound biased here but really
this is a great product and it's a
family it's a full solution for you
and i will end with my uh
my part of explaining the technology and
my colleague will now explain to you a
bit more of the scientific part of
course what you can get out of this
because this is not just showing the
technology but it's for you to
understand how it can help in your
research
thank you very much telma and hello
everyone from my side
now i'll give you a brief introduction
about the tumor micro environment and
then i will present some data from
different types of cancer generated by
the maximum
so what does the tumor micro environment
mean
well the tumor micro environment is a
very busy traffic
in which many different components such
as cancer cells immune cells these are
immune cells that are resident
in the tissue or infiltrating immune
cells and these are coming from outside
the tumor for example from the
bloodstream
and in the tme we also have
extracellular matrix proteins and
several secreted factors
on the left
side europe surface schematic of
proposed mechanism of action
of normalization strategies of the tme
to improve immunotherapy
combined administration of immunotherapy
with stroma and or vascular
normalization
restores vascular functionality and
elevates solid stress
leading to improved tumor perfusion and
oxygenation
uh skewing tumor associated macrophages
terms polarization away from the
immunosuppressive m2o like phenotype to
the m1 like phenotypes these are
macrophages with pro-inflammatory
phenotype
and boosting immunity for example cd4
positive and
t cell cd8 positive t cells and thus
enhancing cancer shell killing
so the biological process occurring in
the tumor micro environment play an
important role in tumor development and
do affect the clinical outcomes
of cancer patients
in this table on the right you see that
effects of the immune infiltrate on the
prognosis of patients with cancer
and
in
you also see the irrelevances of cd
a positive t cells
tertiary employee structures tls
uh regulatory t shells t rx
cd 68 positive backward phases
m
and more specifically macrophages of an
m1 and or m2 subtype to overall survival
outcomes
so the presence of cda t cells
tls as well as m1 macrophages in the tme
is a good sign and indicates positive
prognosis
however
the detection of m2 macrophages
cd68 macrophages as well as t-rex
in
is in most of the cases associated with
negative prognosis
now let's have a look at some example of
pain points that make gme research
challenging
the tme consists many shell types and
many structures and these
make it difficult to understand what is
going on there
there are lots of complex interactions
and processes going on in the tme
it's very important to understand tme
heterogeneity
we need to know where is the location of
these interactions and processes so the
spatial distribution is important
the maxima and its mixed technology
offer you amazing options to overcome
many of these challenges
now i would like to show you some
examples of data
generated using the maxima and the mix
technology
this is about the characterization of
the
tertiary lymphoid structures in the
tumor micro environment
but before i show you data
let me say some few words
about the tls
this cartoon shows a tls located within
a tumor
please see maximize view in the middle
of the slide
with a cd3 positive t cell zoom
containing dc lysosome associated
membrane glycoprotein
abbreviated
dc lamp
with
dendritic shells
and fibroblastic reticular shells and a
cd20 b cell zoom with a germinal center
plasma cells antibodies forming immune
complexes with tumor antigens and
follicular dcs
the coordinated actions of cd8 positive
cytotoxic effector t cells and b cells
generated in tls enable incident tumor
destruction via direct tumor shell
killing the so-called antibody dependent
cellular cytotoxicity mediated by
macrophages and or natural killer cells
and
local complement activation
so central memory t and b cells
generated in tls circulate and protect
against metastasis
in some cancers
tls located in inflamed regions adjacent
to to a tumor may save as a niche for
tumor cell progenitors or or tumor
so the tls is a very important structure
in the tumor micro environment
now i would like to present you the
first story
where the tls was investigated in
ovarian cancer sample
you see the tumor tissue represented by
the epcom sigma in green
and the associated leukocyte
mark by cd45 in red
the nuclei are depicted in blue and
resists are shown by the cd31 signal
the massive accumulation of leukocyte
adjacent to the tumor already indicates
that this could be tls
but we can dig a little bit
deeper
and have
a look at more compositions of the tls
structure which can further
support this
data in this image you see b shells
distribution in the structure
b cells are shown in purple a cd20
signal
and the bsl signal appears as a zoom
which is as mentioned earlier one of the
tls characteristics
but where are the t cells
and this image you observe
an overlay of seven markers indicating
the tumor cells in green
various immune cells including b cells
and purple is 10 with cd20 plasma cells
in white distinct with cd 138
myeloid cells in yellow is 10 with cd14
and in the cellular cells in red is 10
was make a 79 which is a marker of high
endothelial venules
abbreviated as heads
this data was generated by our research
and development
using the maxima
showing biomarker screening in
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
in each image you observe
an overlay of three markers including
dapping in blue epcom in red
representing the tumor signal
and the marker
of interest shown as green signal
the marker specific name is written in
white on each image
and here the initially tested
97 markers
but unfortunately four markers did not
show any signal
and i think
we can appreciate how much valuable data
we can obtain using this technology
uh this result is collected from the
recent brilliant work published in
nature communications by our research
and development colleagues
the idea behind this work was to
identify
cathy cell target candidates in
pancreatic adenocarcinoma
using different methodologies
among them
the maximized mixed technology allowed
them to generate fascinating data
and helped the identification of
specific quality targets
so
in this result the cytokeratine staining
in is shown in green
which is showing the tumor signal that
are being
in blue and the markers of interest are
stained you know red
and i want
all candidates related to the markers
that are quite suppressed
with the tumor cells
which means that these
that the selected direct signal that are
co expressed with the green signal
so these markers were only specific with
it for the tumor
and the perfect candidates they selected
are the ones
that are surrounded by red square here
these are cla
cd66 and cd 318
this result is from the same study
here they took advantage again of the
maximal platform
they looked at cartesian infiltration on
tumors treated with either
cd66c or with cd 318 car t shells
you should see the car t shells in
purple as they are stained with lmg fr
which is the car t shell reporter marker
cd 318 cartesians infiltrated the tumor
and did great job and this
resulted in less tumor presence
and combined with the observation of
cartesian infiltration
in case of cd 318 rigid group
they observed
cd68 microphone infiltration which is
really interesting observation
and in the pepper they performed a
validation experiments which confirmed
these findings
in my last story i would like to show
you
the brand new data generated from brass
breast cancer sample
we start by looking at different cell
populations
here the tumor shell is shown in cyan
color
the fiber lost in red and the nuclei is
turning dappy in blue
here we observe a white distribution of
the fibroblast
outside the tumor
as well as in between the tumor
here we detected t cell signal in red
however mostly distributed outside the
tumor
but we also observe some relatively few
t cells close to the tumor
and this image will observe that some of
the t cells are actually cd positive
cd8 positive t cells
overlay signaling in yellow
here we looked at hlr dr signal
the presence of the hla dr
signal
in this image proves the existence of
mhc
class 2 receptors which is also one of
the tls
characteristic
features
interestingly in this breast cancer
sample we were able to detect
anti-apoptotic signal this is bcl2
signal depicted in red
outside and within the tumor
and in fact
the role of pcl2
in restricting apoptosis and its
widespread suppression in in breast
cancer has attracted attention as a
therapeutic target for many years
we also observe a key
67 signal shown here in green
indicating
cell proliferation
now i would like to wrap up
by summarizing the benefits of the
maximize mix technology for tme research
using this technology you can do
comprehensive characterization of the
tumor micro environment components and
also understand their spatial
distribution without having to worry
about any marker limitations
if you are interested in identifying
tumor-specific targets for cellulose
therapies
then you have an amazing solution
of course with complex investigations
comes complex amount of data to analyze
here you can rely on the
qi
tissue image analysis software
for the maxima
there are several amazing analysis
options you can use in this software
for detailed tissue analysis options
using this software please watch
the on demand webinar highlighting the
benefits of the maximum in lung cancer
presented by my colleague dr
santos we know
that human
tumor samples are precious and and
sample availability for research is in
many cases a challenge so through this
technology you can obtain large amount
of
data from a single tissue section
and
finally
and most importantly
our internal experts at milton invite
okay ready to guide you throughout the
whole
ultra high content
imaging workflow in your tme research
and this is our disclaimer
thank you very much for your attention
and now we are happy to take your
questions
thank you tilma and nazar for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question is
how is the stripping stepped step
performed is this automatically handled
any signal loss after repeated stripping
um
this is a good question actually
no the the process does not include
stripping yeah so the signal is erased
by photo bleaching
using our floral force
and
another
erase mechanism this technology uses is
controlled fluorocarbon
release of the fluorophore
using the realise technology which is
developed by miltoni
so
this is an automatic process
done by the machine as soon as the
experiment starts you don't need to do
anything again so
just relax
thank you nizar the next question
is there a limit for the number of
markers and how much can we go how many
can we do
our record is 400 markers yeah and we
are testing more in house to break this
record so please stay tuned to get the
results of the next race
great thank you nazar our next question
what is the largest field of view and
what is the best resolution possible
cellular subcellular lots of questions
there
hi i will take care of this one now
so the field of view is defined by our
camera but we actually can do several
regions of interest with a lot of fields
of view
our field of view is about 500 microns
per 250 but there is no limitation the
amount of
field of views or roids that you can do
it's basically the size
of your
your sample so of course the maximum
would be
just slightly under a full slide but
that is
what we can do right now
right resolution sorry i forgot the
resolution so the resolution the best
possible is around the 400
425 nanometers and it's enough for
sub-cellular resolution
great thank you thomas the next question
can you elaborate a little bit about the
options for data quantification how
user-friendly is the maxima qi software
thank you i'll take also this one
so the qi software which will be
officially released very soon is very
very nice to use it's it has been tailor
made for actually uh this kind of data
it's super interactive um so i would
invite people who are interested in the
maxima but also in the qit she's always
contact us and
we will have a pleasure to show you or
have you try it
but we also have available on our
website some videos about it so feel
free to check it on and ask us
for whatever you need
thanks again telma the next question are
the antibodies available from you or
collaborating vendors
okay so i'll take this one so we have a
big amount of antibodies that are tested
and validated for
the use within the maxima software um
instrument but
of course it's also possible to use
antibodies from other vendors
basically you just need to fulfill some
basic requirements which are being
primarily conjugated to one of our
photobleachable fluorophores so feed cp
and apc
and be sure that you have a desired
staining within 10 minutes of incubation
because that is how the process works
within the machine if antibodies fulfill
these requirements you are free to use
also
antibodies from other companies
thank you talma our next question
let's see would it be possible to image
organotypic slices with 350 nanometer
thickness or micrometer sorry thickness
using the maxima
i'll go for this question
the max imaging technology is based on
white field fluorescence microscopy so
for the best result
yeah of course thin sections
are preferable so from three up to 10
micrometer
and in our experiments we averagely use
five micrometer
sections
thank you nazar our next question
can a process slide be stored and
analyzed with new markers and for how
long
um so a process slide can
should be able to be stored and analyzed
with new markers you just have to be
aware of the conditions of your slide of
course so
be aware that we do not remove the
antibodies from the sample so
you in principle cannot use the same
markers again
and of course a sample that is within a
buffer
can depending on the quality of the
sample
last more or less
so it really depends on your protocols
of maintaining your sample but in
principle this is possible yes
the how long i would say in general
because
if you use a
a
pfa or an ffp that has already been
retrieved i would say a couple of weeks
to be on the safe side but as we know
scientists tend to test these limits
themselves and this is very very
dependent on the sample and the quality
of the sample that you're dealing with
thank you thomas
another question what type of data
output does the imaging analysis
software generate
so that's a great question
so
yeah so qitc you will analyze your
images and will have a quantification
after segmentation based on your cells
or if you want to do a kind of image
segmentation based on on pixel sizes you
can also
so we have
outputs as
regular csv files and you can also have
the raw data output as
fcs files that can be read in some flow
in most of the flow
softwares
so this is the numerical data that comes
out of qi tissue but you can also of
course out of the maxima we generate
regular omit files so any image and
other software will be in principle able
to read this kind of data as well
thank you again thomas the next question
can i use my own antibodies or do i have
to use special antibodies with the
maxima
um i think my colleague telma touched
that question already but i can
elaborate again yeah that's not a
problem at all so you are free to use
your own antibodies as long as they are
fulfilling the requirements of the mixed
technology so meaning that the
antibodies should be primary antibodies
conjugated to a bleachable fluorochrome
and they should be able to stain with a
good signal in 10 minutes at home
temperature so which should
suits their
maximus training mechanism and in-house
we we used our own mix validated
antibodies yeah but no it's not
restricted to melt any mixed validated
antibodies at all
thank you nazar yes i think we have two
very similar questions i really
appreciate your answer
the next question
how many samples can be analyzed at once
uh so this kind of
sorry for the echo so this
the amount of sample depends clearly on
your uh reagents actually so uh it it
really depends on your reagents what
kind of chamber
and um
and and the amounts that you have
but we
currently are more or less limited to uh
one slide but we focus primarily on the
amount of markers that you can do in one
sample but just a side note the we are
thinking this instrument to be able in
the future to analyze more of course
but the primarily goal of the maxima is
to analyze a high amount of numbers in
one single sample
thank you telma
our next question does the mics
technology have preference to specific
type of fixation
actually the mixed technology has
nothing to do with the fixation but of
course your antibodies need to be
compatible with the fixation you are
using
we have a large imaging antibody
portfolio that is compatible with all
types of fixation whether it's ppf ffpe
or
pfa or acetone fixed tissue or cells so
whether it's from human or mouth samples
yeah you can check that in our website
if you're interested
thank you nazar i want to clarify it's
mixed technology i've mispronounced it
so i apologize for that next question
can you simultaneously run an experiment
and analyze a previous one are data
transferred from one to the other as
they are produced or at the end of the
experiment
so
normally the the
the data will be
available
as it is made but of course
it depends on your kind of analysis if
you need to uh to wait for all the
markers to start your analysis uh you
will have to wait for the end of the
of the run
but in principle you can start analyzing
if you wish for example to um
for example to start for example the
segmentation parameters that can take a
long time you could in principle do it
the maxima is equipped with two
computers so in principle you will have
one computer dedicated to the experiment
run and one for to the analysis so this
should be possible without really
affecting the experiment
great thank you telma the next question
looks like a follow-up question so
output data is quantitative
yes i remember that question yeah yeah
so it's quantitative yes we have a
list of very uh usual features related
to to the floor of fluorescence um but
also the shape and the location of the
cells after segmentation so all of this
is quantitative and can be analyzed in
different ways and manners
but it's a it's a very quantitative way
for sure
great thank you so much for that
clarification thomas our next question
how does the technology cope with
autofluorescent tissues
that i just forget again a great
question i think that if we have in the
audience people who are used to uh deal
with ffb6 tissue we all know that
autofluorescence can be a pain also in
some kind of tissue specifically
like the lung
or even the brain it can be also a bit
difficult so
there is an initial step when we do
the run that will do a long photo
bleaching to ensure that your the
fluorescence is removed
uh but we have to say that the images
are acquired always as a signal image
and we also acquire after signal erasure
in every cycle
and when we process the images to stitch
them together
and to register everything we also do a
step where we remove the signal for the
from the last um
if you want erasure signal this way we
are removing most of the signal that is
still maintained that can come from
autofluorescence or any uh
anything that you might got after it but
you have access to all of these images
so you can follow up how
how good the run
has been but in principle when you have
your images ready to analyze all the
autofluorescence and
and some background signal has been
removed
thank you telma our next question
how can you ensure that the signal from
one cycle is not detected in the sub
subsequent cycle in case the erasure is
not 100 efficient
yes so this come a bit as a continuing
part of what i said before so because we
always take pictures in between cycles
after a signal erasure we make sure
when we're processing the images that we
are removing this signal that might
still be there because of other
fluorescence um and and this way we are
sure that the images that come out
after processing are really ready to be
analyzed without all these issues
thanks again telma it looks like we have
time for one more question is photo
bleaching damaging to the sample
no not at all yeah so it's a very gentle
process
yeah so
actually you don't need to worry about
sample damage
thanks for that answer nazar we
appreciate that and uh thank you both
talmud and nazar do you have any final
comments for the audience today
uh i would like to thank everyone who
assisted to uh this webinar today it was
a pleasure to also answer your questions
i hope that we shed some light on our
technology uh just wanted to say that
you have available on our website
a lot of information and of course if
you have a bit more of interest do not
hesitate in contacting us we will be
more than happy to guide you through
this technology if you need to
nisa do you want that yeah and thank you
very much also from my side
thank you for your attention and
i wish
all of you a great day
i'll see you next time
fantastic thank you again telma and
desire for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank labyrinth and our sponsor miltoni
biotek for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye